Ist das interstellare Objekt “Oumuamua”
doch eine Aliensonde oder zumindest ein Überrest.
Ein Forschungsteam hat jetzt die Bahn durch
unser Sonnensystem überprüft und festgestellt,
dass dieses Objekt viel zu leicht für ein
Objekt aus Stein oder Eis war, also weder
ein Asteroid oder Komet sein kann.
Und sie konnte sogar ausrechnen wie diese
Sonde beschaffen war.
Wir fassen hier alle Fakten zusammen und kommen
zu einem wirklich unglaublichen Schluss!
Und der ist wirklich mindblowing!
Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt es täglich
Wissenschaftsvideos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts.
Herzlich willkommen!
Verrückt, verrückt.
Was hat uns da im September letzten Jahres
besucht?
Ein Brocken aus Gestein oder Eis kann es nicht
gewesen sein.
Schon früh schied Eis, wie bei einem Kometen
aus.
Dafür hätte das Objekt in der Nähe der
Sonne verdampfen müssen.
Und jetzt ist auch Gestein aus dem Rennen.
Die Flugbahn passt einfach nicht zu einem
Objekt aus Gestein.
Und es ist noch mehr mysteriös an dem Objekt.
Wir hatten darüber berichtet: Ein Forschungsteam
der “Initiative Breakthrough Listen” hatte
eine große Abhöraktion gestartet.
Mit Radioteleskopen wollten sie den den mysteriösen
Brocken über mehrere Frequenzen abhören.
Wo kommt Oumuamua her?
Woraus besteht er?
Sendet er Signale außerirdischer Intelligenz?
Aber es blieb alles ruhig.
Doch das ändert nichts daran: Oumuamua bleibt
mehr als mysteriös und Forschungsteams weltweit
suchen fieberhaft nach neuen Erkenntnissen
oder zumindest Hinweisen, um seine Identität
zu klären.
Denn es sind mehr Fragen offen als beantwortet.
Fest steht nur: Es handelt sich um das erste
interstellare Objekt, das nicht aus unserem
Sonnensystem stammt und dessen Durchflug wir
beobachten konnten..
Oumuamua ist das erste interstellare Objekt,
der eindeutig identifiziert werden konnte.
Wegen ihm gibt es jetzt eine neue Kategorie
der Internationalen Astronomischen Union:
I für interstellar.
Wir haben es hier also mit 1 I zu tun.
Und 1 I hat wirklich ziemlich verrückte Eigenschaften,
wie jetzt Shmuel Bialy und Abraham Loeb von
der Harvard University herausbekommen haben.
Demnach und jetzt bitte festhalten: So wie
es sich beim Flug durch unser Sonnensystem
verhalten hat, vor allem wie stark es sich
durch den Sonnendruck beschleunigen lies,
hatte es einen Radius von 20 Metern und deine
Dicke von 0,3 bis 0,9 Millimeter.
What?
Das ist wirklich der absolute Wahnsinn!
Wie kann das sein?
Es gibt zwei Erklärungen und eine davon ist
ziemlich unwahrscheinlich.
Die eine ist, dass es sich um ein neues natürlich
vorkommendes superdünnes Material handelt
und die andere, dass es eine Aliensonde oder
die Überreste einer Aleinsonde.
Und das unwahrscheinlich ist hier, dass das
natürliches Material sein könnte.
Insbesondere, da es sich beim Vorbeiflug an
der Sonne als perfekter Reflektor herausgestellt
hat.
So schnell wurde es beschleunigt.
Hierbei gibt es jetzt zwei Thesen: Weltraumschrott
einer fremden Zivilisation oder eine Sonde,
die ganz bewusst zu uns geschickt wurde um
Daten über die Erde zu gewinnen.
„Wenn wir eine künstliche Herkunft in Betracht
ziehen, so wäre eine Möglichkeit, dass es
sich um ein im interstellaren Raum treibendes
Lichtsegel als Reste eines fortschrittlichen
technologischen Geräts handelt.
Lichtsegel mit ganz ähnlichen Dimensionen
wurden bereits von unserer eigenen Zivilisation
angedacht und entwickelt, etwa vom IKARUS-Projekt
oder der Breakthrough Starshot Initiative.
Die Lichtsegel-Technologie könnte vielfach
etwa für den Transport zwischen einzelnen
Planeten oder Sternensystemen genutzt werden.“
Und auch hier gibt es wieder eine unwahrscheinlich
und eine wahrscheinlich Vermutung.
Als Trümmerteil, das nur zufällig durch
unser Sonnensystem geflogen wäre, würde
es Rückschlüsse auf die Anzahl solcher Objekte
in unserem Sonnensystem geben und das wären
eine Billiarde solcher Objekte pro Stern.
Gegenüber sagte Loeb: „Die Alternative
ist, sich vorzustellen, dass` Oumuamua auf
einer Aufklärungsmission war.
Der Grund, aus dem ich über die Aufklärungsmöglichkeit
nachdenke, besteht darin, dass die Annahme,
dass Oumuamua einer zufälligen Umlaufbahn
folgte, die Erzeugung von ~ 10 ^  Objekten
pro Stern in unserer Galaxie erfordert.
Diese Fülle ist bis zu hundert Millionen
Mal höher als vom Sonnensystem erwartet,
basierend auf einer Berechnung, die wir im
Jahr 2009 durchgeführt haben.
Ein überraschend hoher Überfluss, es sei
denn, Oumuamua ist eine gezielte Erkundung
einer Aufklärungsmission und kein Mitglied
einer zufällige Population von Objekten."
Und da geht es noch um natürliche Objekte.
Also wie sollen so viele künstliche Objekte,
wie gesagt, pro Stern durch unsere Galaxie
fliegen?
Da ist dann im Moment nur noch eine Erklärung
plausibel: Oumuamua muss eigentlich zwingend
eine Aliensonde sein.
Und das eigentlich füge ich nur ein, weil:
Wie soll ich hier und wie soll Loeb so eine
Behauptung aufstellen ohne sich auf sehr dünnes
Eis zu begeben.
Wir können keine Daten mehr gewinne.
Die Sonde ist weg.
Loeb geht aber noch einen Schritt weiter.
Er vermutet, dass es sich ursprünglich um
eine ganze Armada solcher Sonden gehandelt
haben könnte und nur eine dieser Sonden es
geschafft hat wirklich unser Sonnensystem
zu treffen beziehunsgweise wir nur eine der
Sonden entdeckt haben.
Und jetzt könnte man natürlich mal gucken
wer dieser Loeb überhaupt ist.
Vielleicht ist er ja irgendein Spinner, der
hier irgendwelchen Blödsinn verbreitet.
Aber weit, sogar ziemlich weit gefehlt.
Loebe ist niemand geringeres als Professor
für Astrophysik an der Harvard University,
Direktor des Institutes for Theory & Computation
(ITC) im Harvard-Smithsonian Center for Astrophysics
und Vorsitzender des Fachbereiches Astronomie
der Harvard University.
Upsi.
Das ist ja man richtig seriös!
Jetzt bleibt nur noch eine Frage: Woher?
Und auch da wissen wir etwas: 1I Oumuamua
kam aus der Richtung des Sterns Wega im Sternbild
Leier und drang von oben in unser Sonnenensystem
ein.
Wir sollten also mal ganz schnell unsere Teleskope
in diese Richtung drehen und nachsehen, wie
es genau dort in 25 Lichtjahren Entfernung
so aussieht.
Es wäre nicht verwunderlich, wenn wir da
einen Exoplaneten mit idealen Bedingungen
finden würden.
Im Orbit von Wega selbst ist das eigentlich
eher unwahrscheinlich.
Dort rotiert eine Scheibe aus Staub rund um
den Stern.
Er stammt wahrscheinlich aus der Kollision
zweier Planeten.
Wir müssen also etwas genauer hinschauen.
Wenn ihr kein Video dazu verpassen wollt,
dann abonniert am besten auch den englischen
Kanal (hier einfach draufklicken) von Clixoom.
Da gibt es auch die ein oder andere Videopremiere.
Glocke nicht vergessen und hier geht es weiter
mit: The First picture of Earth and moon!
Stay tuned, see you soon!